At Medcan, we know that life's greatest moments are built on a foundation of good health, from the big milestones to the quiet winds. That's why our annual health assessment offers a physician-led, full-body checkup that provides a clear picture of your health today, and may uncover early signs of conditions like heart disease and cancer. The healthier you means more moments to cherish. Take control of your well-being and book an assessment today. Medcan. Live well for life.
在 Medcan，我们深知人生中最伟大的时刻都建立在健康的基础之上，无论是重大的里程碑还是宁静的微风。正因如此，我们的年度健康评估提供由医生主导的全身检查，为您呈现当下的健康状况，并可能及早发现心脏病和癌症等疾病的迹象。您越健康，就越能拥有更多值得珍惜的时刻。掌控您的健康，立即预约评估。Medcan，为您的一生健康生活。
Visit medcan.com slash moments to get started. It won't take long to tell you neutral's ingredients. Vodka, soda, natural flavours. So, what should we talk about? No sugar added? Neutral. Refreshingly simple. Hello everyone.
访问 medcan.com/moments 即可开始。很快就能告诉您 Neutral 的成分。伏特加、苏打水、天然香料。那么，我们该聊点什么呢？不添加糖？Neutral。清爽纯粹。大家好。
I am here with some exceedingly exciting news. Now, as all our beloved club members will already know, one of the very best things of being a member of the rest of history club is getting access to exclusive members-only miniseries. That's right. Miniseries, not just individual episodes. So these are special episodes every other month, which only club members can listen to. No one else. And we've got a brand new one coming out this February. So that's going to be the very first one of 26. And it is presented by me and the great art critic Laura Cumming, four episodes and it's about paintings that shed a particularly fascinating light on history and
我带来了一些非常令人兴奋的消息。正如我们所有亲爱的俱乐部成员所知，成为“历史余韵”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）成员最棒的事情之一，就是可以独家访问会员专享的迷你剧集。没错，是迷你剧集，而不仅仅是单集节目。这些是每隔一个月推出的特别剧集，只有俱乐部成员才能收听。其他人都不行。我们今年二月将推出一个全新的系列。这将是 2026 年的首个系列。它由我和伟大的艺术评论家劳拉·卡明（Laura Cumming）共同呈现，共四集，内容是关于那些以特别迷人的视角阐释历史的画作，并且
it covers a broad range of times and places. So everything from Velazquez's Las Meninas, described by many critics as the greatest of all paintings, right the way up to Henry Rayburn's Skating Minister. What do these paintings tell us about the times in which they were painted? It's really, really fascinating stuff. Members will get a new one of those episodes every Wednesday and it is starting this week on the 4th of February. So that's the Wednesday. And if you are not watching it on YouTube or Spotify, if you're just listening to it as a podcast, don't worry because we will be sending all our members an email, which will be going into greater written detail about the painting, but also obviously giving you an
它涵盖了广泛的时间和地点。从委拉斯开兹的《宫娥》（Las Meninas）——被许多评论家誉为有史以来最伟大的画作——一直到亨利·雷伯恩（Henry Raeburn）的《滑冰的牧师》（The Skating Minister）。这些画作向我们揭示了它们创作时代的哪些信息？这真的非常非常迷人。会员每周三都会收到其中一集，本周 2 月 4 日开始。也就是周三。如果您不是在 YouTube 或 Spotify 上观看，而只是作为播客收听，也不必担心，因为我们会给所有会员发送一封电子邮件，其中会有关于画作更详细的文字说明，当然也会为您提供
image of the painting itself. So you can have a quick look at that perhaps before you listen to the episode, although I have to say that Laura's descriptions of each painting are so good that perhaps you don't even need to look at the painting. So if you would like to sign up to that miniseries and to the other five miniseries that we will be doing this year, which will be covering everything from history's greatest photographs, the Vietnam War, to England's she-wolves, then you know where to go. Go to the rest ishistory.com if you are not already a club member and sign up there. Masinissa had already heard a great deal about Scipio's prowess as a general and hugely admired him.
画作本身的图片。这样您在收听剧集之前或许可以先快速浏览一下，尽管我必须说，劳拉对每幅画的描述都非常精彩，以至于您可能根本不需要看画。所以，如果您想订阅这个迷你剧集以及我们今年将制作的其他五个迷你剧集（涵盖从历史上最伟大的照片、越南战争到英格兰的“母狼”等一切内容），那么您知道该去哪里。如果您还不是俱乐部成员，请前往 therestishistory.com 注册。马西尼萨（Masinissa）早就听说过西庇阿（Scipio）作为将军的英勇，并对他极为钦佩。
The Numidian had formed a picture of the Roman in his mind's eye as a man of powerful and striking physique. But when at last he came face to face with Scipio, he was awe-struck. for in the flesh the Roman general was even more impressive than he had been in Massinissa's imaginings that was Welsh exciting naturally possessed of great dignity
这位努米底亚人（Numidian）在脑海中将这位罗马人想象成一位体格强健、外表出众的男子。但当他最终与西庇阿面对面时，他被震撼了。因为现实中的这位罗马将军比马西尼萨想象中的还要令人印象深刻，那是一种威尔士式的兴奋，自然而然地流露出巨大的尊严。
Scipio also thanks to his longer air cut a most graceful figure this however owed nothing to any effeminate fussing over fashion or personal grooming but rather to an appearance and bearing
西庇阿也因为他较长的头发而显得姿态优雅，但这绝非源于任何女性化的时尚或个人修饰，而是源于一种外表和风度，
that was virile indeed stream, for he was the very model of a warrior. Scipio was just at the age when his physical powers were at full strength, and even though he had recently been ill, he had quite recaptured his youthful bloom. Indeed, he seemed more handsome than ever. So that was Rob Bryden describing one of history's more homoerotic summit meetings. Actually, it was the Italian-born Roman historian, Livy. So that was your Roman accent, was it? That was the accent of an Italian.
那确实是阳刚之气，因为他简直是战士的典范。西庇阿正处于体力处于巅峰的年纪，尽管他最近生过病，但他已经完全恢复了青春的光彩。事实上，他看起来比以往任何时候都更英俊。刚才那是罗伯·布莱顿（Rob Bryden）在描述历史上更具同性恋色彩的峰会之一。实际上，那是出生于意大利的罗马历史学家李维（Livy）。所以那是你的罗马口音，是吗？那是意大利人的口音。
But actually, as it went on, it degenerated into the accent of an Italian who had set up an ice cream parlor and Swansea in the 1910s. Dominant, you and Welsh history, we just can't stop you doing it. It's great to have some Welsh history back on the show. So that was the Roman historian Livy, and he's describing this exciting meeting in 206 BC. We are on the Atlantic coast of Iberia, now Spain, and the participants are two extremely strapping, well-oiled and handsome warlords. One of them is Massinisa, who is a Berber prince from modern-day Algeria, New Media, as it then was, and the other is Publius Cornelius Scipio,
但实际上，随着谈话的进行，它退化成了 1910 年代在斯旺西开设冰淇淋店的意大利人的口音。多米尼克，你和威尔士历史，我们就是无法阻止你这样做。很高兴节目中又有了威尔士历史。所以那是罗马历史学家李维，他正在描述公元前 206 年那次激动人心的会面。我们现在位于伊比利亚（现西班牙）的大西洋沿岸，参与者是两位极其强壮、油光满面且英俊的军阀。其中一位是马西尼萨，他是来自现代阿尔及利亚（当时的努米底亚）的柏柏尔王子，另一位是普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·西庇阿（Publius Cornelius Scipio），
who is a Roman patrician, a young man whom we met in their previous episode. And Scipio, listeners may recall, was the officer whom, 10 years before this meeting, had rallied the Met of Rome in the wake of their shattering defeat at Can I, and he had made them swear, never to desert our country, nor to permit any other citizen of Rome to leave her in the lurch. So, 10 years on, here he is meeting this oiled warlord. Tom, explain what's going on. Well, I mean, an extraordinary a way of accents, for starters. But there are some other puzzles as well. first of all, attentive listeners may be wondering, what is a Numidian doing meeting up with a Roman? Because
他是罗马贵族，我们在上一集见过这位年轻人。听众可能还记得，西庇阿就是那位在坎尼会战（Battle of Cannae）惨败后，召集罗马人并让他们发誓“绝不背弃我们的国家，也不允许任何其他罗马公民抛弃她”的军官。所以，十年过去了，他在这里会见这位涂了油的军阀。汤姆，解释一下发生了什么。嗯，首先，这口音真是太离谱了。但还有其他一些谜团。首先，细心的听众可能想知道，一个努米底亚人为什么要和罗马人会面？因为
people who've listened to our previous episodes in this ongoing series will recall that the Numidians are the allies not of Rome, but of Carthage. And in fact, they are key allies, because they are the best like cavalry in the world. They ride bareback. They don't bother with reins. They have spears all kinds of things. And they are the horsemen who have provided Hannibal effectively with the cutting edge throughout his invasion of Italy and his occupation of Italy. And the Romans have learned to dread the Namedians possibly more than any other of the units in Hannibal's army. So what is going on here? And secondly, what on earth is up with Scipio? Because Dominic, you read this This kind of stern traditionalist statement of Roman pluck and determination.
听过我们这个系列节目之前剧集的听众会记得，努米底亚人不是罗马的盟友，而是迦太基的盟友。事实上，他们是关键盟友，因为他们是世界上最好的轻骑兵。他们骑马不带马鞍，也不用缰绳。他们有长矛，什么都有。他们是那些在汉尼拔入侵意大利和占领意大利期间，实际上为他提供了尖端战力的骑兵。罗马人学会了畏惧努米底亚人，可能超过了汉尼拔军队中的任何其他部队。那么这里发生了什么？其次，西庇阿到底是怎么回事？因为多米尼克，你读了这段话，这是一种严厉的、传统的罗马式果敢和决心的声明。
I mean, Skippy is only 19 when he's saying that. So he's very, very old school. I mean, it's patriotic in exactly the way that Roman traditionalists expect young men to be patriotic. But something has changed and something very, very sinister. If you recall, people who are paying attention to that reading and frankly who wasn't, Scipio now has long hair, the most un-Roman thing imaginable. So is he like you going to India on your gap, yeah? Is that what's going on?
我的意思是，西庇阿说这话时才 19 岁。所以他非常非常守旧。我的意思是，这正是罗马传统主义者期望年轻人表现出的那种爱国主义。但有些事情已经改变了，而且是非常非常险恶的改变。如果你回想一下，那些注意听那段朗读的人（坦率地说，谁没注意呢），西庇阿现在留着长发，这是最不罗马的事情了。所以他就像你一样，去印度度间隔年了吗？这就是发生的事情吗？
Well, I mean, someone else he went to India, of course, is Alexander the Great. And there's a definite hint of Alexander there. And what is also a hint of Alexander is the fact that, according to Pliny the elder, admittedly writing centuries later, but I think we can rely on him. Scipio was the first Roman to shave daily. So up until that point, Romans had generally been bearded, but now Scipio has introduced this fashion for a clean chin. And that again, of course, is very, very Alexander. And when you think of that description, that passage that you read, the sense of awe that Massenissa feels at seeing this kind of divine godlike figure, I mean, it's quite Homeric. It's the way that people are described in the Iliad, for instance, seeing Achilles. So all in all, in all, Scipio is cutting, for Roman traditionalists, a disturbingly kind of Greek dash. Because Roman commanders are supposed to be old and craggy and bearded and all of that.
嗯，我的意思是，当然还有其他人去过印度，那就是亚历山大大帝。那里确实有亚历山大的影子。而且亚历山大的另一个暗示是，根据老普林尼（Pliny the Elder）的说法——尽管是几个世纪后写的，但我认为我们可以信赖他——西庇阿是第一个每天刮胡子的罗马人。在那之前，罗马人通常留着胡子，但现在西庇阿引入了这种干净下巴的时尚。当然，这又非常非常像亚历山大。当你想到那段描述，想到马西尼萨看到这种神一般的人物时感到的敬畏，我的意思是，这非常荷马史诗。就像《伊利亚特》中人们描述看到阿喀琉斯（Achilles）的方式。所以总而言之，对于罗马传统主义者来说，西庇阿展现出了一种令人不安的希腊风情。因为罗马指挥官本应该是苍老、粗犷、留着胡子的。
And they are not supposed to look like Achilles. They are not supposed to look like Alexander the Great. So something odd is absolutely going on here. So when Livy is describing Scipio, there is a sense here, isn't there, that Scipio is more than an ordinary Roman general, as you've described really. this business about Alexander the Grave, for example. There is a sense, isn't there, in Livy's description, that Scipio is his marketing himself as something actually quite old-fashioned as a Greek style, as indeed a Homeric hero, right?
他们不应该看起来像阿喀琉斯。他们不应该看起来像亚历山大大帝。所以绝对有什么奇怪的事情正在发生。所以当李维描述西庇阿时，这里有一种感觉，不是吗？西庇阿不仅仅是一个普通的罗马将军，正如你所描述的那样。比如关于亚历山大大帝的这件事。李维的描述中确实有一种感觉，即西庇阿正在将自己营销为一种实际上相当老派的东西，一种希腊风格，确实是一位荷马式的英雄，对吧？
Somebody who has been appointed by the gods to lead the Romans back from the abyss of Cannae and Lake Trasamine and all the defeats that Hannibal is inflicted on them. And do you think this is a conscious thing? And do you think Livy is genuinely reported? Skipio's PR strategy, as it were. This is how Livy puts it. He absolutely says it's a PR strategy. So to quote Livy, from Skipio's earliest days, he used to present his policies and actions
一个被神任命带领罗马人从坎尼和特拉西梅诺湖（Lake Trasimene）的深渊，以及汉尼拔对他们造成的所有失败中走出来的人。你认为这是有意识的吗？你认为李维真的报道了西庇阿的公关策略吗？李维是这样说的。他绝对说是公关策略。所以引用李维的话，从西庇阿很小的时候起，他就习惯于将他的政策和行动
as inspired by dreams or by warnings from heaven. And this is very ostentatiously performative. So Livy tells us that, Skipio, before he takes any course of action, he will go up to the capital very obviously and sit in the Temple of Jupiter as though he is communing with the God. And this in turn fosters what Livy describes as a very empty and foolish story once told of Alexander the Great, that Scipio had been born from the embraces of a giant serpent, a monster that had often visited his mother in her bedroom, but had always glided away and vanished the moment someone came in. I mean, skeptics may say, well, there's absolutely no evidence for this at all,
表现为受到梦境或来自天堂的警告的启发。这非常有表演性。所以李维告诉我们，西庇阿在采取任何行动之前，都会非常显眼地走到卡比托利欧山（Capitol），坐在朱庇特神庙里，仿佛在与神交流。这反过来又助长了李维所描述的一个关于亚历山大大帝的非常空洞和愚蠢的故事，即西庇阿是由一条巨蛇的拥抱所生，这只怪物经常拜访他母亲的卧室，但每当有人进来时，它总是滑走并消失。我的意思是，怀疑论者可能会说，这完全没有证据，
but clearly what Scipio is doing is trying to imply that the serpent might have been due to. Because, of course, Dominic, you will remember that very similar stories were told of Alexander, that Jupiter had come in the form of a snake to Alexander's mother. So, Scipio doesn't, obviously doesn't deny these stories, does he? Why would he? As Livy says in his account, whether he was truly so superstitious as to believe this nonsense or whether he fostered reports of it so that people would obey him the more is unclear. So Scipio just lets the stories kind of build and build.
但很明显，西庇阿这样做是想暗示那条蛇可能是朱庇特。因为，多米尼克，你当然会记得关于亚历山大的类似故事，说朱庇特曾以蛇的形式出现在亚历山大的母亲面前。所以，西庇阿显然没有否认这些故事，对吧？他为什么要否认呢？正如李维在他的叙述中所说，他到底是真迷信到相信这些废话，还是为了让人们更服从他而助长了这些传言，尚不清楚。所以西庇阿只是让这些故事不断发酵。
Now, I guess Scipio knows that what the Romans are cravings, is, well, at first what they were craving was a figure of reassurance, right? A conservative figure, a memory of Roman virtues past. But he's changing, isn't he? And he's developing a new strategy to sort of impress his personality on the Roman masses. And he's becoming, I dare, I mean, Tom, you have compared him in your notes to a rock star. He's turning himself into a figure of kind of rock star glamour and charisma. He's very good-looking. He's very swagger. He's very swar. and he's kind of promoting himself as possibly as the son of a god. And of course, he is in a republics. And republics don't tend to look favourably on kind of rock stars posing as the son of a
现在，我想西庇阿知道罗马人渴望的是什么，起初他们渴望的是一个令人安心的人物，对吧？一个保守的人物，对过去罗马美德的记忆。但他正在改变，不是吗？他正在制定一种新的策略来给罗马大众留下深刻印象。他正在成为——我敢说——汤姆，你在笔记中把他比作摇滚明星。他正在把自己变成一个具有摇滚明星魅力和吸引力的人物。他长得很帅。他非常傲慢。他非常时髦。他正在把自己宣传为可能是神的儿子。当然，他身处共和国。而共和国往往不太看好那种冒充神之子的摇滚明星。所以一定有一些人认为这家伙是个糟糕的人。我的意思是，他爱炫耀且轻浮。我的意思是，这实际上是人们以后会对许多罗马人物提出的抱怨，不是吗？是的。但西庇阿建立了一个品牌，正如你所说，许多未来的罗马人会效仿，一直到共和国实际上已经崩溃并被帝国取代的时期。但西庇阿为这些后来出现的年轻、爱炫耀的皇帝开辟了道路。但西庇阿最终会……所以很多听众可能已经知道了。
god. So there must be some people who think this guy's a terrible person. I mean, this is, that he's showy and brash. And I mean, this is actually a complaint that people will level a lots of Roman figures to come, isn't it? Yes. But Scipio is establishing a brand that, as you say, many Romans to come will copy well into the period when the Republic has actually collapsed and been replaced by an empire. But Scipio is blazing the path for, you know, these kind of younger, showboating emperors who will appear. But Scipio is going to end up. So a lot of people listening to this may already know.
西庇阿最终将成为汉尼拔的伟大对手。在研究古典世界的人的想象中，他们两人是联系在一起的。他们的相遇、他们的决斗将成为布匿战争（Punic Wars）的伟大转折点。西庇阿给了罗马人他们一直渴望的一样东西，那就是他们自己拥有汉尼拔那种魅力、吸引力和军事效能的人物。实际上，汉尼拔的出身相对较好，不是吗？在迦太基方面。而西庇阿的出身也非常好。
Scipio is going to end up as the great antagonist of Hannibal. The two of them are kind of linked in the imagination for people who study the classical world. And their encounter, their duel will become the great turning point in the Puneit Wars. And Scipio gives the Romans the one thing they've craved all this time, which is their own figure with the glamour, the charisma, and the effectiveness, the military effectiveness of Hannibal. Actually, Hannibal is relatively well-born, isn't he, in Carthaginian terms. And Scipio is also extremely well-born.
我的意思是，他非常时髦。他去了哈罗公学。基督堂学院。也许是基督堂学院，还是他去了达勒姆？不，他去了基督堂学院。因为他……我的意思是，他是贵族中的贵族。而且他非常聪明。他非常有魅力。我的意思是，他拥有一切。因为他是贵族。所以他来自罗马古老的贵族王朝之一。但话虽如此，实际上，西庇阿家族只是最近才在政治上崭露头角。基本上，布匿战争成就了西庇阿家族和他们的声誉。所以早在第一次布匿战争中，他们中的两个人就表现得足够好，获得了凯旋式。西庇阿的叔叔叫卡尔武斯（Calvus）。他的绰号是卡尔武斯，意思是秃头。他在公元前 222 年担任执政官，是一位因打击高卢人而闻名的大人物。罗马人总是喜欢那些能击败高卢人的人。而卡尔武斯的兄弟，西庇阿的父亲普布利乌斯，人们可能还记得，在公元前 218 年担任执政官，那一年汉尼拔入侵了意大利。诚然，他在那场战役中并没有什么光彩的表现。他试图阻止汉尼拔入侵意大利，但失败了，而且在特雷比亚战役（Battle of Trebia）前受伤了。但他并没有完全
I mean, he is positively posh. He went to Harrow. Christchurch. Maybe Christchurch, or did he go to Durham? No, he went to Christchurch. because he I mean, he's the poshest of the posh. And he's very smart. He's very charismatic. I mean, he's got it all. Because he is a patrician. So he is from one of the ancient aristocratic dynasties of Rome. But having said that, actually, the Scipio's have only recently come into political prominence. And basically, the Punei Wars has been the making of the Scipio's and their reputation. So back in the first Punei War, two of them had done well enough to be awarded triumphs. Scipio's uncle is called Calvus. He's nicknamed Calvus, which means baldy. He had been consul in 222 and was a great man for having a crack at the Gauls. The Romans always like people who could defeat the Gauls. And Calvus's brother, Scipio's father, Publius, people may remember, had been consul in 218, which was the year that Hannibal had invaded Italy. And admittedly, he hadn't exactly covered himself in glory in that campaign. He tried to stop Hannibal from. invading Italy and failed and he'd been injured before the Battle of Trebia. But he hadn't totally
搞砸一切。与其他与汉尼拔交战的执政官的记录相比，我的意思是，那并不算太糟。我认为这向罗马人民和罗马政府表明，普布利乌斯有一种基本的胜任能力。在罗马面临的危机规模下，这被认为是足够的。因此，到公元前 217 年，这两位西庇阿兄弟——年轻西庇阿的叔叔卡尔武斯和他的父亲普布利乌斯——都被派往伊比利亚，即西班牙。澄清一下，后来的西班牙显然是罗马帝国不可分割的一部分。哈德良（Hadrian）来自西班牙，不是吗？
screwed things up. And compared to the record of other consuls who had taken on Hannibal, I mean, that's, you know, that's not bad. And it suggested, I think, to the Roman people, to the Roman government, that Publius, he had a kind of a basic competence. And that in the scale of the crisis that Rome was facing was considered to be enough. And so by 217, both these Skippio brothers, Calvus, who is the young Scipio's uncle, and Publius, his father, they have been sent to Iberia, to Spain. And to clarify, so Spain later on, it's obviously an integral part of the Roman Empire. Hadrian comes from Spain, doesn't he?
但在当时，也就是基督诞生前 200 年，对于罗马人来说，西班牙是一个非常陌生、异国情调且可怕的地方。它就像科幻史诗中的东西。就像被派往一个敌对的星球，因为它到处都是用自己的尿液刷牙的敌对野蛮人。我的意思是，完全令人震惊。他们掌握着一种致命的武器。这是一种短刺剑，通过剖开对手的内脏来发挥作用。你刺进去，然后切开，所有的内脏都会流出来。罗马人称这种武器为“格拉迪乌斯”（Gladius），这个词后来被罗马学者从拉丁语词“cladais”中衍生出来，
But at the time, so, you know, we're 200 years before the birth of Christ, Spain is a very alien and exotic and terrifying place for the Romans. It's like something out of a science fiction. epic. It's like being sent to a hostile planet because it is teeming with hostile barbarians who clean their teeth with their own urine. I mean, completely shocking. And they are masters of a lethal weapon. And this is a short stabbing sword which works by eviscerating an opponent. You plunge it in and you slice it up and all the guts spill out. And the Romans call this weapon a Gladius, which is a word that later Roman scholars will derive from the Latin word cladais,
意思是屠杀。它们几乎是屠杀敌人的代名词。罗马人已经体验过格拉迪乌斯，因为汉尼拔带了很多伊比利亚人到意大利。不出所料，因为罗马人非常非常善于适应，特别是在军事方面，他们已经开始为自己使用格拉迪乌斯并开始掌握它，但面对一个满是天生就会使用这种武器的战士的半岛，显然令人不安。所以我认为西庇阿兄弟到达时的首要任务，在伊比利亚西北部有一个罗马前哨站，基本上就是现在的加泰罗尼亚，他们的首要责任是不被消灭。这是一个巨大的挑战，
which means slaughter. They're kind of synonymous with butchering your enemies. And the Romans have already experienced the gladius because Hannibal has brought lots of Iberians with him to Italy. And unsurprisingly, because the Romans are very, very adaptive, particularly when it comes to kind of military matters, they have begun to use the gladius for themselves and a start to master it, but obviously it's unsettling to be up against a whole peninsula full of warriors who were born basically to use it. And so I think that the prime duty of the Scipio brothers, when they arrive, and there's a kind of Roman outpost in the northwest of Iberia, basically what's now Catalonia, their prime responsibility is not to be wiped out. And this is a huge challenge
因为当意大利的消息从坏变到最坏时，他们被派往那里。所以汉尼拔一直在对罗马人造成我们在上一系列中提到的那些令人难以置信的失败。特拉西梅诺湖战役刚刚结束。你知道，整支军队被消灭，一名执政官被杀，诸如此类。这意味着元老院真的无法派遣多少人、物资或现金来贿赂西班牙的当地部落。因此，实际上，这两位西庇阿兄弟被困在了——让我们不合时宜地称之为——加泰罗尼亚。
because they have been sent as the news back in Italy is going from bad to worst. So Hannibal has been inflicting, you know, these incredible defeats on the Romans that we did in the previous series. Lake Trasamine has just been fought. You know, an entire army has been wiped out, a consul killed and all of that. And this means that the Senate can't really send many men or many, you know, or supplies or indeed cash to bribe the local tribes to Spain. And so effectively, the two Scipio brothers are penned into, let's call it, Catalonia, anachronistically.
冒险离开那里对他们来说很危险。所以，如果你把西班牙想象成有点像弗兰克·赫伯特（Frank Herbert）小说《沙丘》（Dune）中的厄拉科斯（Arrakis），你知道，他们被围困了，他们觉得离开那里很危险。我认为，如果人们把我们今天讲述的整个故事看作是很容易提供那种以遥远星球为背景的史诗科幻小说情节的东西，他们就不会错得太离谱。强大银河帝国的冲突，诸如此类。好的，为了提醒大家我们到底在哪里，我们回到了汉尼拔在意大利横冲直撞的时候。我们和两位西庇阿兄弟在一起，也就是我们的西庇阿，那个长发帅哥。
It's dangerous for them to venture out of that. So they, if you think of Spain perhaps as being a little bit like Arachis, Dune in the Frank Herbert novels, you know, they are hemmed in and they feel that it is perilous to leave that. And I think that if people have a sense of this whole story that we're doing today as something that could very easily provide the plot of a kind of one of those epic science fiction novel set on distant planets. They will not be far wrong. The clash of mighty galactic empires, that kind of thing. Okay, so to remind people exactly where we are, we are back at the point when Hannibal is kind of cutting a sway through Italy. We're with the two Scipio brothers who are our Scipio, so the long-haired boat.
那是他的父亲和叔叔。所以我们算是回到了过去。所以我们在西班牙。对他们来说，问题在于他们现在面对的不仅仅是一个迦太基将军，不仅仅是拿着这些花哨剑的伊比利亚人，而是整个迦太基帝国现在控制了伊比利亚半岛的整个南部，不是吗？
It's his father and uncle. And so we've sort of gone back in time. So we're in Spain. and the problem for them is that they are now facing, not just, you know, one Carthaginian general, and not just the Iberians with these fancy swords, but the entire Carthaginian Empire now controls the whole of the southern part of the Iberian Peninsula, doesn't it?
此时在这个地区负责迦太基人的是汉尼拔的弟弟哈斯德鲁巴（Hasdrubal）。他拥有一支相当强大的力量，13,000 名步兵，3,000 名骑兵。他有 21 头战象。他拥有所有这些矿山，这实际上是西班牙财富的关键，也是西班牙对局外人如此有吸引力的原因。所以黄金、白银、铜。他有一座我们上次谈到的城市。他们称之为迦太基。罗马人称之为新迦太基（New Carthage）。这是迦太基帝国在西班牙的中心和基地。这座城市坐落在四座山上，俯瞰着一个梦幻般的港口。直到今天，它仍然是西班牙的……
And the guy in charge of the Carthaginians at this point in this part of the world is Hannibal's younger brother, Hasdrable. And he has with him a pretty mighty force, 13,000 infantrymen, 3,000 cavalry. He has 21 war elephants. He's got all these mines that are the key really to Spain's wealth is what makes Spain so attractive to outsiders. So gold, silver, copper. And he has a city that we talked about last time. They've called it Carthage. The Romans call it New Carthage. And this is the sort of center, the base of the Carthaginian Empire in Spain. And this city is on four hills, overlooking a fantastic harbour. It's to this day one of Spain,
卡塔赫纳（Carthagena）是西班牙的主要海军基地之一。你知道，像地中海世界各地的许多城市一样，它拥有这些令人惊叹的防御工事。它有一条直接通往矿山的道路，这使它极其富有。基本上，如果迦太基人哈斯德鲁巴能守住这个，那么西庇阿兄弟，
Carthagena is one of Spain's key naval bases. You know, like so many cities across the Mediterranean world, it's got these amazing fortifications. And it has a direct road link with the mines that makes it extremely rich. And basically, if Hasdrubal, the Carthaginian can keep hold of this, then the Scipio brothers,
基本上他们想做什么就做什么，但他们无法将他从伊比利亚半岛赶走。所以希腊历史学家波利比乌斯（Polybius），我们关于布匿战争的最佳来源，他将其描述为迦太基在西班牙帝国的首要装饰和中心，因为它不仅与腹地的矿山相连，而且当然也向海洋开放。所以它使新迦太基能够与迦太基，当然还有意大利进行交流。
basically they can do what they like, but they're not going to dislodge him from the Iberian Peninsula. So the Greek historian Polybius, who is our best source for the Puneic Wars, I mean, he describes it as the chief ornament and the centre of the Carthaginian Empire in Spain, because not only is it linked to the mines in the hinterland, but it is also, of course, open to the sea. So it's what enables New Carthage to communicate with Carthage and, of course, with Italy.
这意味着哈斯德鲁巴和迦太基的当权者可以协调努力，试图筹集增援部队，然后将其送往意大利。这绝对是不言而喻的，是罗马人最不希望发生的事情。他们不想要第二个巴卡（Barca）兄弟。所以汉尼拔·巴卡，哈斯德鲁巴·巴卡。他们不希望哈斯德鲁巴·巴卡带着另一支庞大的迦太基军队出现在意大利，
And what this means is that Hasdrable and the powers in Carthage can coordinate to try and raise reinforcements that can then be sent onwards to Italy. And this is absolutely, it goes without saying, the last thing that the Romans want. They do not want a second Barker brother. So Hannibal Barker, Hasdrable Barker. They do not want Hasdrable Barker turning up in Italy with yet another massive Carthaginian army
带着他的大象、他的努米底亚人和他们那可怕的刺剑的西班牙人等等。所以本质上，西庇阿兄弟之所以在伊比利亚的西北角，在比利牛斯山脉附近，本质上是为了阻挡哈斯德鲁巴通往南高卢的通道，这样他就不能跟随汉尼拔进入意大利。他们的目标不仅是阻止汉尼拔，还要试图征服并赢得尽可能多的伊比利亚部落。理想情况下，你知道，为罗马征服他们。但如果他们做不到，那么至少要培养反迦太基情绪，这样哈斯德鲁巴就会忙于
with his elephants and his Namedians and his Spaniards with their terrifying stabbing swords and so on. So essentially the Skippio brothers are where they are, in the northwest corner of Iberia by the Pyrenees, essentially to block off Hasdribal's access route to southern Gaul so that he can't follow Hannibal into Italy. And their objective is not just to stop Hannibal, but to try and conquer and win over as many of the Iberian tribes as possible. And ideally, you know, conquer them for Rome. But if they can't do that, then at the very least, kind of foster anti-Carthaginian feeling so that Hasdrable will have his hands full
试图平息西班牙的叛乱。而哈斯德鲁巴的目标显然是筹集一支庞大的军队，穿过高卢进入意大利。对于罗马人来说，最危险的时刻出现在公元前 215 年的春天，也就是坎尼会战后的第二年。哈斯德鲁巴筹集了一支庞大的特遣部队。他离开了新迦太基。正如汉尼拔三年前所做的那样，他率领这支庞大的军队向北推进。他的目标是越过比利牛斯山脉，穿过高卢，与他在意大利的兄弟会合。如果他成功了，汉尼拔的兵力将增加一倍。在坎尼会战之后，很难看出罗马人如何能够继续战斗。所以这确实是战争中的关键时刻。所以两位西庇阿，他们基本上站在他的
trying to kind of put out rebellions in Spain. And Hasdribal's goal is obviously to raise an enormous army and march through Gaul into Italy. And for the Romans, the supreme moment of peril comes in the spring of 215, which is the year after Can I. And Hasdrable has raised an enormous task force. And he leaves New Carthage. And as Hannibal had done three years before, he advances northwards at the head of this vast force. And his aim is to cross the Pyrenees, advance through Gaul, and join his brother in Italy. And if he's successful, then Hannibal's forces will be doubled. And it is hard to see in the wake of Cannae how the Romans then would have been able to carry on the fight. So this is really a crucial moment in the war. So the two Scipio's, they are basically standing in his
路上，他们在伊贝拉（Iberra）镇外，埃布罗河（River Ebro）以南会见了哈斯德鲁巴。这实际上是历史上最重大的战役之一，可以说，几乎没人听说过。因为正如你所说，如果哈斯德鲁巴成功越过阿尔卑斯山，与意大利的汉尼拔会合，这对罗马人来说看起来真的很危险。但汤姆，在伊贝拉战役中发生了什么？这实际上是一场罗马的胜利。确实。罗马步兵，他们最强大的兵种，与迦太基步兵相遇，基本上消灭了他们。哈斯德鲁巴能够带着他的骑兵撤退，所以这不是一场彻底的胜利。但它足以阻止哈斯德鲁巴向意大利的继续进军。
way, and they meet Hasdrubal just south of the river Ebro, outside a town called Iberra. and this is actually one of the most significant battles in history, arguably, that nobody has ever heard of. Because as you say, if Hasdribal manages to cross the Alps, join Hannibal in Italy, that looks really dicey for the Romans. But what happens, Tom, at the Battle of Iberra, it's actually a Roman victory. It is. The Roman infantry, always their strongest arm, meet with the Carthaginian infantry and essentially wipe them out. Hasdribal is able to withdraw with his cavalry, so it's not a total victory. but it is sufficient to abort Hasrable's onward march to Italy.
所以有一种说法是，这是战争的决定性时刻，绝对是历史上最决定性但没人听说过的战役称号的候选者。然而，正如我们所说，它并没有彻底消灭哈斯德鲁巴，因为他带着骑兵撤退了。在那一年（公元前 215 年）末，一位非常非常迷人的人物加入了伊比利亚。这就是哈斯德鲁巴，也就是汉尼拔最小的弟弟。这是一个叫马戈（Mago）的家伙。我们在关于汉尼拔入侵的系列节目中谈到过马戈。
So there is a case for saying that this is the decisive moment of the war, absolutely a candidate perhaps for the title of the most decisive battle in history that no one has ever heard of. However, as we say, it doesn't finish Hasdribal off because he has withdrawn with his cavalry. And towards the end of that year, 215, he is joined in Iberia by a very, very glamorous figure indeed. This is Hasdrable and therefore Hannibal's youngest brother. And this is a guy called Mago. And we talked about Mago in our series about Hannibal's invasion.
马戈曾陪同汉尼拔进入意大利。他表现得非常好。所以在特雷比亚战役中，汉尼拔的第一次伟大胜利，人们可能记得迦太基骑兵躲在一些灌木丛后面，然后突然跳出来从后方攻击罗马人。马戈领导了他们。所以，你知道，在那场胜利中起到了绝对关键的作用。在坎尼，他站在他兄弟身边，处于迦太基战线最关键和最脆弱的位置。
Mago had accompanied Hannibal into Italy. And he had done very well. So at the Battle of Trebia, the first of Hannibal's great victories, people may remember the Carthaginian cavalry had hidden behind some bushes and then sprung out and attacked the Romans in the rear. And Mago had led them. So, you know, an absolutely crucial part in that victory. At Can I, he had stood next to his brother in the most critical and vulnerable position in the Carthaginian line.
所以他非常勇敢。他随后被汉尼拔派往迦太基宣布坎尼大捷的消息，他做得非常浮夸，带回了一个巨大的麻袋，里面装满了从罗马军队中被屠杀的大人物身上取下的金戒指。他把那袋戒指倒在迦太基元老院的地板上。元老院里的每个人都印象深刻，即使是那些通常对巴卡兄弟非常敌视的人，因为他们嫉妒和怨恨他们。迦太基元老院决定，你知道，我们需要介入。所以他们投票筹集更多军队，
So he's incredibly brave. He had then been sent by Hannibal to Carthage to announce the news of the great victory at Cannae, which he had done very flamboyantly by bringing in an enormous sack full of the gold rings that had been taken from the slaughtered bigwigs in the Roman army. And he kind of empties the sack full of rings onto the floor of the Carthaginian Senate House. and everyone in the Senate is enormously impressed, even people who normally would be very hostile to the Barker brothers because they're kind of jealous and resentful of them. And the Carthaginian Senate decides, you know, we need to weigh in here. And so they have voted to raise more troops,
步兵、骑兵、大象，并为此买单。这些部队现在已经从迦太基航行到新迦太基，哈斯德鲁巴的兵力再次膨胀。所以回顾一下，我们现在在伊比利亚半岛的西班牙面临这样一种情况：我们有两支敌对的军队，一支罗马的，一支迦太基的，由两对敌对的兄弟领导。所以这真的感觉像是弗兰克·赫伯特疯了。没错。人们还没有开始变成沙虫，但这非常科幻，不是吗？是的。
so infantry, cavalry, elephants, and to pay for it. And these have now sailed from Carthage to New Carthage and Hasdrubles forces have now been swollen again. So to recap, we now have a situation on the Iberian Peninsula in Spain where we have two rival armies, one Roman, one Carthaginian, led by two rival pairs of brothers. So this really does feel like sort of Frank Herbert's gone mad. Exactly. People haven't yet started turning into sandworms, but it's very science fiction, isn't it? Yeah.
我的意思是，只有在科幻史诗或第二次布匿战争中，你才会遇到这种情况，两对敌对的兄弟在一个奇怪、陌生的景观中面对面。基本上，他们现在势均力敌。所以卡尔武斯和普布利乌斯成功阻止了哈斯德鲁巴将增援部队带到意大利。你知道，他们觉得自己在履行职责。但马戈，他是西班牙最能干的指挥官，他成功地让当地的伊比利亚人忠于迦太基，并阻止了罗马人试图向北部飞地之外扩张的每一次尝试。最后，在公元前 211 年，西庇阿兄弟想，哦，这太荒谬了。我们必须突围。我们必须尝试，你知道，把战斗带给迦太基人。所以他们向南进军新迦太基，但一切都变得非常糟糕。所以首先，
I mean, only in a science fiction epic or the second Punic War would you have a situation where you have two rival sets of brothers facing each other in a weird, alien landscape. And basically, they're now pretty evenly matched. So Calvus and Publius, they succeed in blocking Hasdrubel from leading reinforcements to Italy. You know, they feel that they're doing their job. But Mago, who is by far the ablest commander in Spain, he succeeds in keeping the native Iberians loyal to Carthage and blocking every attempt the Romans make to expand beyond their northern enclave. And finally, in 2.11, the Skippeo brothers think, oh, this is ridiculous. We've got to break out. We've got to try and, you know, take the battle to the Carthaginians. And so they march southwards towards New Carthage, but it all goes horribly wrong. So first,
马戈消灭了一支由普布利乌斯（西庇阿的父亲）领导的军队。几天后，哈斯德鲁巴粉碎了第二支罗马军队，这支军队由卡尔武斯（西庇阿的叔叔）领导，普布利乌斯和卡尔武斯都被杀了。这两次失败背后有两个特别的因素。第一个是，我的意思是，我们可以称之为两位罗马指挥官采用的“小大角”（Little Big Horn）策略。他们基本上分散了兵力，这意味着迦太基人更容易将他们各个击破。但另一个因素是迦太基军队中出现了一位杰出的年轻骑兵指挥官。这就是我们已经见过的家伙。这就是马西尼萨，那位努米底亚人，他被……你被围困了。
Mago wipes out an army led by Publius, who was Scipio's father. And then a few days later, Hasdribal crushes the second Roman force, which was being led by Calvus, Scipio's uncle, and both Publius and Calvus are killed. And two factors in particular lie behind these twin defeats. And the first is the, I mean, we could call it the little big horn strategy that had been adopted by the two Roman commanders. They had essentially divided their forces, meaning that it then became easier for the Carthaginians to pick them off. But also another factor was the presence in the Carthaginian ranks of a brilliant young cavalry commander. And this is a guy we have already met. This is Massinissa, the Numidian who was so besie. And, you were so besieged.
被年轻西庇阿的神一般的外表所迷住。所以此时，他才 20 岁出头，但他已经非常非常老练了。他已经代表他在非洲的父亲打赢了一场针对另一位努米底亚国王西法克斯（Syfax）的战争，我们稍后会听到关于他的消息。所以他击败了西法克斯。他让他父亲保住了努米底亚的王位。现在他率领 3,000 名骑兵抵达西班牙，在那里对抗罗马人。他和他的骑兵在追击西庇阿兄弟领导下的罗马人走向毁灭的过程中发挥了主导作用。李维记录了细节。日日夜夜，他都会切断那些远离营地寻找木材或饲料的罗马小分队。马西尼萨经常直接骑到
sotted by the godlike appearance of the young Scipio. So at this point, he is barely 20, but he's already very, very seasoned. He'd already won a war on behalf of his father back in Africa against a rival Numidian king called Syfax, who we will be hearing about later. So he's seen off Syfax. He's kept his dad on his throne in Numidia. And now he's arrived in Spain at the head of 3,000 horsemen, and he is there to serve against the Romans. And he and his cavalry had played the leading role in harrying the Romans under the two Scipio brothers to their doom. And Livy records the details. Day and night, he would cut off parties of Romans who were distant from their camp in search of wood or fodder. Often, Massinissa would ride right up to the
营地本身，并全速冲过守卫它的前哨站，造成了最可怕的混乱。所以，多亏了哈斯德鲁巴和马戈，特别是这位风流倜傥的努米底亚王子马西尼萨，迦太基在西班牙的存在，当然还有对那些关键矿山的控制，看起来是稳固的。因为你会认为，如果罗马人在意大利本土与汉尼拔进行生死搏斗，他们将无法抽出或召集新的力量在西班牙进行战争。当然，问题是，即使他们能，他们还能派谁去担任指挥官呢？
camp itself and charge at the gallop through the outposts guarding it, causing the most terrible confusion. So, thanks to Hasdrubel and Mago, and particularly to this swashbuckling Numidian Prince Massinisa, it looks like the Carthaginian presence in Spain, of course, access to those crucial minds, is secure. Because you would think that if the Romans are fighting a life or death struggle with Hannibal in Italy on home territory, they will not be able to spare or to muster new forces to prosecute the war in Spain. And the question, of course, is even if they could, who on earth would they have left to send as their commander?
嗯，答案就在那里，肯定在马西尼萨身上。正如亚历克斯·弗格森（Alex Ferguson）在 1996 年告诉你的那样，有时你必须启用年轻人。也许这就是罗马人现在必须做的，不是吗，汤姆？因为他们基本上处于，他们叫什么来着？《沙丘》里的弗雷曼人（Fremen）。塔维（Tavi）在聊天中说，不错。我告诉他们一点《沙丘》的内容。是的。所以，正如你所说，迦太基人拥有他们的
Well, the answer is there, surely, in Massunisa. As Alex Ferguson would tell you in 1996, sometimes you have to reach for the kids. And maybe this is what the Romans have to do now, isn't it, Tom? Because they are basically in the position of, what are they called? The Fremen in Iraqis in June. Tavi says, nice. in the chat. I'm telling them to a bit of June. Yeah. So, as you say, the Carthaginians have got their
那种风流倜傥的年轻人。现在是罗马人召唤他们自己的风流倜傥的年轻人的时候了吗？如果他们要这样做，这个风流倜傥的年轻人可能是谁？多米尼克，他们能在哪里找到一位“沙丘救世主”？休息后我们将回答这些问题。加拿大各地的本地新闻正在衰落。这对我们所有人来说都是坏消息。随着本地新闻的减少，噪音、谣言和错误信息填补了空白。区分事实与虚构变得越来越难。这就是为什么 CBC 新闻正在加拿大各地投入更多的记者。从您居住的地方进行实地报道，
kind of dashing youth. Is it time that the Romans summon up a dashing youth of their own? And if they're going to do that, who could this dashing youth possibly be? Where, Dominic, can they find a Dune Messiah? We'll be answering these questions after the break. Local news is in decline across Canada. And this is bad news for all of us. With less local news, Noise, rumors, and misinformation fill the void. And it gets harder to separate truth from fiction. That's why CBC News is putting more journalists in more places across Canada. Reporting on the ground from where you live,
讲述对我们所有人来说都很重要的故事。因为本地新闻就是大新闻。选择新闻，而不是噪音。CBC 新闻。使用运通白金卡（Amex Platinum），您可以在全球范围内使用超过 1,400 个机场贵宾室。所以您起飞前的体验就是未来体验的预演。这就是运通强大的支持。适用相关条款。
telling the stories that matter to all of us. Because local news is big news. Choose news, not noise. CBC News. With Amex Platinum, you have access to over 1,400 airport lounges worldwide. So your experience before takeoff is a taste of what's to come. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply.
你好，我是汉娜·弗莱（Hannah Fry）教授。我是迈克尔·史蒂文斯（Michael Stevens）。我们共同主持《科学余韵》（The Rest is Science），这是 Gollhanger 推出的全新节目。每周我们都会以全新的视角审视熟悉的事物。我们将探索塑造我们生活、思考和看待世界方式的力量、理论和现象。我们将剖析我们认为理所当然的事物，以
Hello, I'm Professor Hannah Fry. And I'm Michael Stevens. Together we host The Rest is Science, a brand new show from Gollhanger. Every week we take a fresh look at the familiar. We're going to be exploring the forces, the theories and the phenomena that shape how we live in, think about and see the world. We're going to pull apart what we take for granted to. reveal the unexpected patterns and hidden logic just beneath the surface.
揭示表面之下意想不到的模式和隐藏的逻辑。因为这就是推动科学进步的原因，不是打磨答案，而是磨砺问题。正是好奇心激发了那些“嘿，等等，那到底是怎么运作的”时刻，改变了我们看待世界的方式。是的，我的意思是，科学不是一门学科。它是一种看待世界的方式。它是一种注意到所有隐藏在众目睽睽之下的非凡事物，并意识到熟悉的事物从来都不平凡的方式。请留到本集结束，抢先收听。如果好奇心战胜了你，请每周二和周四加入我们，收听《科学余韵》的新剧集。欢迎回到弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，回到《历史余韵》。现在是公元前 210 年。我们身处罗马城。
Because that's what moves science forward, not the polishing of answers, but the sharpening of questions. It's curiosity that sparks those, hey, wait, how does that actually work kind of a moment that changes the way we see the world? Yeah, I mean, science isn't a subject. It's a way of seeing it. It's a way of noticing all of the extraordinary things that are hiding in plain sight, and realizing that the familiar was never ordinary at all. Stick around until the end of this episode for a first listen. And if curiosity gets the better of you, join us every Tuesday and Thursday for new episodes of The Rest is Science. Welcome back to Frank Herbert's June, to The Rest is History. It is 210 BC. We are in the city of Rome.
因为这才是推动科学进步的动力，不是对答案的润色，而是对问题的深究。正是好奇心激发了那些“嘿，等等，那到底是怎么运作的？”的瞬间，从而改变了我们看待世界的方式。没错，我的意思是，科学不是一门学科，而是一种观察世界的方式。它是一种去发现那些隐藏在眼皮底下的非凡事物，并意识到熟悉的事物从来都不平凡的方法。请收听本集节目直到最后，抢先试听。如果你的好奇心被勾起来了，欢迎每周二和周四加入我们，收听《科学的其余部分》（The Rest is Science）的新剧集。欢迎回到弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。现在是公元前210年，我们身处罗马城。
And amid the marble halls of Hollywood's imagination, a young man called Scipio, Publius Cornelius, Scipio, 25 years old. He's suspiciously clean-shaven, even more suspiciously, long-haired. There's talk that he has been fathered by a snake. And this young man has just been elected by public vote to command of the Roman armies in Iberia in Spain. Now, Tom, I said elected by public vote. This is unusual, isn't it? Because isn't normally the Senate that appoints commanders rather than the Roman people? Yeah, it's very unusual. Because as you say, the Senate is very jealous of its prerogative. The Senate has the right to appoint commanders. What are the people doing, poking their noses into this important business? Because it is taken for granted that commanders should be elected magistrates. But Skipio is not an elected magistrate. He is a privatus, a private citizen. And it is also the Roman custom to put a premium on experience. They tend to regard youth not as something dashing, but as something. potentially sinister, that a Roman commander who is under the age of 40 is generally assumed
在好莱坞想象中的大理石殿堂里，有一位名叫普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·西庇阿的年轻人，年仅25岁。他刮得干干净净的脸庞显得有些可疑，而他那留得更长的头发则更令人怀疑。有传言说他是蛇的后代。这位年轻人刚刚通过公众投票，被选为罗马驻伊比利亚（西班牙）军队的统帅。汤姆，我说的是通过公众投票选出的。这很不寻常，对吧？因为通常不是由元老院任命统帅，而不是由罗马人民吗？是的，这非常不寻常。因为正如你所说，元老院非常看重自己的特权。元老院有权任命统帅。民众为什么要插手这种重要事务呢？因为人们理所当然地认为统帅应该是民选的行政长官。但西庇阿并不是民选的行政长官。他是一个平民（privatus）。而且罗马的习俗也倾向于重视经验。他们往往认为年轻人不是那种意气风发的人，而是某种潜在的危险分子，通常认为40岁以下的罗马统帅
to be kind of impulsive and headstrong and rash. So listeners may therefore be wondering, well, how on earth did the 25-year-old Scipio, you know, this private citizen, how on earth did he manage to get this command? I mean, it's undoubtedly the case that the people adore him. He's glamorous, he's dashing. He provides him with a, you know, a touch of color amid the kind of monochrome grind of the war against Hannibal. And although at the same time, although lots of people in the Senate are indeed suspicious of him, I think there are also lots of them that can recognize the advantages of sending him specifically to Spain. Because remember, he is the son of one of the commanders who'd been in Spain and he is the nephew of another of those
是那种冲动、固执且鲁莽的人。所以听众可能想知道，这个25岁的西庇阿，这个平民，到底是怎么获得这个指挥权的？毫无疑问，民众崇拜他。他魅力四射，意气风发。在与汉尼拔战争那种单调乏味的磨难中，他为人们增添了一抹亮色。虽然与此同时，元老院里很多人确实对他持怀疑态度，但我认为也有很多人能看出专门派他去西班牙的好处。因为记住，他是曾在西班牙任职的统帅之一的儿子，也是另一位统帅的侄子。
commanders. So the name of Scipio in Iberia has a real cachet. And I think that even in the Senate, there are people who feel, well, we would be mad not to capitalize on this. The issue for them is they don't want to be seen to be appointing a 25-year-old. If they do it, it would establish a sinister precedent. And so that's where the popular vote comes in. They can get the people to vote for him. And essentially, they're kind of washing hands of the responsibility. So, Scipio, he gets his command. He leaves Rome. He arrives in Spain.
所以西庇阿这个名字在伊比利亚有着真正的声望。我认为即使在元老院里，也有人觉得，如果不利用这一点就太傻了。对他们来说，问题在于他们不想被视为任命了一个25岁的年轻人。如果他们这样做，就会开创一个危险的先例。所以这就是全民投票发挥作用的地方。他们可以让民众投票选他。本质上，他们是在推卸责任。于是，西庇阿获得了指挥权。他离开罗马，抵达了西班牙。
And the situation that he finds waiting for him is a very, very rocky one. So obviously the Romans have lost two major battles. So their numbers in their kind of enclave in the northwest of Spain are badly depleted. The Iberian tribes, you know, they're busy cleaning their teeth with urine, sharpening their stabbing swords, all of that. These are people who only really respect success. And this in turn means that now the Romans have been so comprehensively defeated by the Carthaginians, they are much likelier to swing Carthaginian-wise. And this obviously is brilliant for the Carthaginian commanders, because their numbers have now swollen and they are able to put three armies in the field. So there is one under Hasdrable, Hannibal's younger brother, which is stationed in central Spain near what's what would today be the city of Toledo. There's another under Mago, who is Hannibal's youngest brother, near the pillars of Hercules, what today is Gibraltar.
他所面对的局势非常非常严峻。显然，罗马人已经输掉了两场重大战役。因此，他们在西班牙西北部据点的人数严重缩减。伊比利亚部落，你知道的，他们正忙着用尿液刷牙，磨快他们的刺剑，诸如此类。这些人只尊重成功。这意味着，既然罗马人已经被迦太基人彻底击败，他们就更有可能倒向迦太基一边。这对迦太基统帅来说显然是极好的，因为他们的人数现在增加了，他们能够派出三支军队上阵。其中一支由汉尼拔的弟弟哈斯德鲁巴率领，驻扎在西班牙中部，靠近今天托莱多市的地方。另一支由汉尼拔最小的弟弟马戈率领，靠近赫拉克勒斯之柱，即今天的直布罗陀。
And there is a third army by the mouth of the Tagus, so that is Dominate your favourite city, Lisbon. I love Lisbon. So the Carthaginians are not thinking about, they don't think they're going to be having to fight a defensive war to maintain their foothold in Spain. They actually are thinking about expanding their empire, as it were. They want to conquer northern Spain.
还有第三支军队在特茹河口，也就是你最喜欢的城市，里斯本。我爱里斯本。所以迦太基人并没有考虑他们是否需要进行防御战来维持在西班牙的立足点。他们实际上是在考虑扩张他们的帝国。他们想征服西班牙北部。
They want to get more manpower. They want to get more mines, more natural resources. And once they've done that, they think, right, we'll finish with the Iberia Peninsula. And then Hasrabal can lead a task force into, you know, through southern France, across the Alps, into Italy, as we have been hoping to do for so long. That, as always, is their prime goal. Yeah. Yeah. So actually, that winter, the Carthaginians do not retire to their base at New Carthage, but they remain.
他们想获得更多的人力。他们想获得更多的矿山和自然资源。一旦做到这一点，他们认为，好吧，我们就搞定了伊比利亚半岛。然后哈斯德鲁巴就可以率领一支特遣部队，穿过法国南部，越过阿尔卑斯山，进入意大利，正如我们长期以来一直希望做的那样。那一如既往是他们的首要目标。是的。是的。所以实际上，那个冬天，迦太基人并没有撤退到他们在新迦太基的基地，而是留在了
in their forward basis because they are on the front foot. It's they believe who are prosecuting the war. Yes. And it's clear as well that they regard Skippeo with contempt. They haven't factored him into this at all. They feel that the Romans have been beaten. And their focus now is essentially, as you say, on conquering the remaining Iberian tribes.
他们的前沿基地，因为他们处于进攻态势。他们认为自己才是战争的发起者。是的。而且很明显，他们对西庇阿嗤之以鼻。他们根本没把他考虑在内。他们觉得罗马人已经被打败了。他们现在的重点基本上正如你所说，是征服剩余的伊比利亚部落。
But this is going to prove a very, very serious mistake because the young Skipio has arrived to take up his command with a very, very bold plan in his head indeed. And so that spring, his first, you know, it's his first campaigning season in Spain. He musters every last soldier that he has. And it comes to about 20,000 infantry, two and a half thousand cavalry. And he heads south along the coast, as his father and uncle had done the previous year. And as he goes, he is shadowed by the Roman fleet. And this is commanded by his closest friend, a guy called Gaius Lilius.
但这将被证明是一个非常非常严重的错误，因为年轻的西庇阿带着一个非常非常大胆的计划来接管他的指挥权了。所以那个春天，他在西班牙的第一个作战季节，他召集了他所有的士兵。大约有2万名步兵，2500名骑兵。他沿着海岸向南进发，就像他父亲和叔叔前一年所做的那样。在他行进时，罗马舰队在侧翼掩护。这支舰队由他最亲密的朋友盖乌斯·莱利乌斯指挥。
And Lilius is the only other person in the task force who knows where they are heading. The only person that Scipio has entrusted with his brilliant plan. So southwards they march along the road, on and on and on. And finally, a week after they've left, so on the seventh day, they arrive before their destination. And this destination, Dominic, is the great city of New Carthage. it's obviously an incredibly bold strategy. It's been fostered by the fact that Scipio knows that the Carthaginian armies are at least 10 days march away. And that the garrison that has been left in New Carthage is basically only about 1,000 strong.
莱利乌斯是特遣部队中唯一知道他们要去哪里的人。是西庇阿唯一信任并告知其宏伟计划的人。于是他们沿着道路向南进军，走啊走。终于，在他们出发一周后，也就是第七天，他们抵达了目的地。这个目的地，多米尼克，就是伟大的新迦太基城。这显然是一个极其大胆的战略。西庇阿知道迦太基军队至少在10天的路程之外，而留守新迦太基的驻军基本上只有1000人左右，这促成了他的计划。
But even so, we've said how it has these kind of bristling fortifications. It's a very, very strong city. I mean, it's a big, big ask to take it. And I think that Scipio's men, when they realize the job that their young general has set them, they feel a bit alarmed. They think, oh, God, actually, you know, everybody says about young commanders is true. They are rash. They are headstrong.
但即便如此，我们已经说过它拥有那种令人望而生畏的防御工事。这是一座非常非常坚固的城市。我的意思是，攻下它是一个非常艰巨的任务。我认为西庇阿的士兵们当意识到他们年轻的将军给他们布置的任务时，感到有些惊慌。他们想，天哪，实际上，每个人对年轻统帅的评价都是真的。他们很鲁莽。他们很固执。
They do come up with mad ideas. But Scipio summons his men and he addresses them. And he appears sublimely self-confident. And he tells them, it is the God Neptune who first suggested this plan to me. So he's now moved on from talking to Jupiter. he's talking to Neptune, the god of the sea. He appeared to me in a dream and has promised to show his support for us
他们确实会想出疯狂的主意。但西庇阿召集了他的士兵并向他们发表讲话。他显得极其自信。他告诉他们，是海神尼普顿首先向我提出了这个计划。所以他现在已经不再谈论朱庇特了，他在谈论海神尼普顿。他出现在我的梦中，并承诺会通过一个壮观的迹象来展示对我们的支持。
by means of a spectacular sign. Well, to be fair, this is very, you're compared with Alexander the Great. This is certainly the kind of stuff that Alexander the Great would come out with and people would say, hurrah, yeah, I completely believe this, let's do it. And actually, you know, it's a good comparison.
平心而论，这确实可以与亚历山大大帝相提并论。这当然是亚历山大大帝会说出来的话，人们会欢呼，是的，我完全相信这一点，让我们去做吧。实际上，这是一个很好的比较。
What happens immediately is that Lilius, the naval commander, you know, he assembles his ships and they surround the harbour, blocking off access. And the main body of Scipio's men launch a massive frontal assault on the city walls. And the defenders are entirely focused on resisting this. Meanwhile, Scipio has recruited a crack squad of elite hand-picked men and he takes them on a secret mission. Because north of the city, there stretches a lagoon. And because the waters are normally so deep,
接下来发生的事情是，海军统帅莱利乌斯集结了他的船只，包围了港口，切断了通道。而西庇阿的主力部队对城墙发动了大规模的正面进攻。守军完全专注于抵御这次进攻。与此同时，西庇阿招募了一支由精锐人员组成的特种小队，并带他们执行了一项秘密任务。因为在城市北面，延伸着一片泻湖。由于海水通常很深，
and because every defender in New Carthage is required to stave off this kind of main Roman assault, The walls that rise above the lagoon are unguarded because they assume that, well, no one will be able to cross the lagoon. So, Scipio arrives with his crack squad of elite handpick men on the shores of the lagoon. And they look out and there it is and then beyond the lagoon are the northern walls of New Carthage. And as they gaze at the walls, there is a palpable miracle because a heron lands and stands in the water. and this reveals to the Romans that the waters are ebbing. You say a miracle, but isn't that pretty standard with waters that they ebb and flow? It turns out that this is in fact a regular phenomenon, that it happens every so often.
而且新迦太基的每一名守军都被要求去抵御罗马人的正面进攻，所以泻湖上方的城墙无人看守，因为他们认为没有人能够穿过泻湖。于是，西庇阿带着他的精锐小队来到了泻湖岸边。他们向外望去，就在那里，泻湖对面就是新迦太基的北墙。当他们凝视着城墙时，一个明显的奇迹发生了，一只苍鹭降落在水中。这向罗马人揭示了水位正在退去。你说这是一个奇迹，但水位涨落不是常态吗？事实证明，这实际上是一种定期现象，每隔一段时间就会发生。
Does it not happen every day? It's not a regular tide, but every so often the tide does go out. And Scipio has been informed about this, and he's worked out that this is the moment when he needs to be there. But obviously, he doesn't tell this to his men, and they all assume that this is the sign from Neptune that Scipio had promised them. And so they wade in through the shallows, reach the base of the walls. They've brought ladders with them. They put them up against the walls. They climb over and there is no one to stop them.
难道不是每天都发生吗？这不是定期的潮汐，但每隔一段时间潮水确实会退去。西庇阿被告知了这一点，他计算出这就是他需要到达那里的时刻。但显然，他没有告诉他的士兵，他们都认为这是西庇阿承诺给他们的来自尼普顿的迹象。于是他们涉水穿过浅滩，到达了城墙底部。他们随身带着梯子。他们把梯子靠在墙上。他们爬了过去，没有人能阻止他们。
And now they can rush forward. They can open the gates of the city. The Romans who've been doing the full frontal assault can pile in as well. And there is unbelievable slaughter. And we know this because Polybius, this Greek historian, he goes on to interview Lilius, who is Scipio's friend who's been in command of the fleet. And he revealed just how brutal the slaughter had been. So to quote Polybius, the practice of the Romans is to inspire terror.
现在他们可以冲锋了。他们可以打开城门。进行正面进攻的罗马人也可以涌入。随后发生了难以置信的屠杀。我们知道这一点是因为波利比乌斯，这位希腊历史学家，后来采访了西庇阿的朋友、舰队指挥官莱利乌斯。他揭示了这场屠杀是多么残酷。引用波利比乌斯的话，罗马人的做法是制造恐怖。
And so when they capture a city, you will often see not just the corpses of human beings, but dogs cut in half and the dismembered limbs of other animals. And Lilius specifies to Bolibius that this is what was happening in New Carthage after the Romans had got in. And so unsurprisingly, the Carthaginian commander, seeing the horror, realizing that he has no prospect of keeping the city, he duly surrenders and so the slaughter stops and new carthage unbelievably is scipios he has seized the great nerve center of the carthaginian empire i mean an amazing coup so this is an extraordinary moment because what this has done is it means that um the romans now have the wealth of new carthage
所以当你占领一座城市时，你经常看到的不仅是人类的尸体，还有被砍成两半的狗和被肢解的其他动物的肢体。莱利乌斯向波利比乌斯详细说明了罗马人进入新迦太基后发生的情况。不出所料，迦太基统帅看到这一恐怖景象，意识到他没有守住城市的希望，便投降了，屠杀停止了。新迦太基难以置信地成为了西庇阿的战利品。他夺取了迦太基帝国的伟大神经中枢。这是一个惊人的政变。这是一个非凡的时刻，因为这意味着罗马人现在拥有了新迦太基的财富。
they have the supplies they have the resources they have the harbour so they have a wonderful link now with the sea and Scipio immediately turns it into what Polybius calls a workshop of war, doesn't he? So he starts to recruit troops, he's drilling them, he's kind of endlessly schooling them in kind of the tactics they will need that he has learned from Hannibal. He's making weapons. And the PR, the propaganda effects of this, perhaps the most crucial element, because basically this is sending a message to the people of the Iberian Peninsula. the Romans are back and they're here in a big way and they are the winners now.
他们拥有了补给，拥有了资源，拥有了港口，所以他们现在与海洋有了极好的联系。西庇阿立即将其变成了波利比乌斯所说的“战争工坊”，不是吗？他开始招募军队，进行操练，不断地用他从汉尼拔那里学到的战术来训练他们。他在制造武器。而公关，即宣传效果，也许是最关键的因素，因为这基本上是在向伊比利亚半岛的人民传递一个信息：罗马人回来了，他们以强大的姿态回来了，他们现在是赢家。
Yeah, and the Iberians love a winner. So by the spring of 208, Hasrable knows he's got a massive crisis on his hands because he's lost his capital, but he is now increasingly losing the loyalty of all these kind of various Siberian warlords who were thinking, well, Scipio's a winner. Let's back him. And a whole posse of warlords by the spring of 208 have decided that they are actually. actively going to back the Romans. And so, again, to quote Polybius, they all prostrated themselves before Scipio and hailed him as king. Of course, the word king is a very dirty word to the Romans.
是的，伊比利亚人喜欢赢家。所以到了公元前208年春天，哈斯德鲁巴知道他面临着巨大的危机，因为他失去了首都，但他现在正日益失去那些认为“西庇阿是赢家，让我们支持他”的各种伊比利亚军阀的忠诚。到了208年春天，一大批军阀决定他们实际上要积极支持罗马人。所以，再次引用波利比乌斯的话，他们都匍匐在西庇阿面前，尊称他为国王。当然，国王这个词对罗马人来说是一个非常肮脏的词。
They are a republic. They don't like kings. But Scipio accepts that, you know, the name has a kind of glamour that will help his cause. And so he, you know, he accepts it, which in the long run won't go down well in Rome, but, you know, needs must. So the issue now for Hasdrable, his rival, Hasdrabel knows that basically the entire war hinges on this, right? Because Carthage really, really needs Spain to continue being at the as well, the top table of international kind of superpower rivalry. Well, and more than that, if they lose Spain, then there's no way that Hannibal can win in Italy. Because if supplies and troops from Spain cannot reach Italy, then in the long run Hannibal will lose. So do you think Hasdrabul at this point is thinking, right, well, I need to really
他们是一个共和国。他们不喜欢国王。但西庇阿接受了这一点，因为他知道这个头衔有一种魅力，有助于他的事业。所以他接受了，这从长远来看在罗马不会有好结果，但形势所迫。所以现在对他的对手哈斯德鲁巴来说，问题在于他知道整场战争基本上都取决于此，对吧？因为迦太基确实非常需要西班牙来继续保持在国际超级大国竞争中的地位。不仅如此，如果他们失去西班牙，那么汉尼拔就不可能在意大利获胜。因为如果来自西班牙的补给和军队无法到达意大利，那么从长远来看，汉尼拔就会失败。所以你认为哈斯德鲁巴此时在想，好吧，我需要真正
force the issue. Let's get this over and done with now, because having lost new Carthage, I can't hang around. So this is why he basically rolls the dice and says, right, we'll go for Italy right now. We will march there with the expeditionary force to give my brother the reinforcements he needs and let's finish this. Yes. And so it is obvious to both sides that this is the great fulcrum point of the whole war. This is the moment of supreme crisis. Everything hangs on what happens next. So obviously, the Romans are desperate to stop Hasdrable. The best way for them to stop Hasdrable joining up with Hannibal is to prevent him leaving Iberia at all. So early that summer, Scipio advances into the depths of Iberia. He attacks Hasdribal's base and he manages to inflict serious
迫使局势发展。让我们现在就解决这个问题，因为失去了新迦太基，我不能再拖延了。这就是为什么他基本上孤注一掷，说，好吧，我们现在就去意大利。我们将带着远征军去那里，给我哥哥他需要的增援，让我们结束这一切。是的。所以双方都很清楚，这是整场战争的巨大支点。这是最高危的时刻。一切都取决于接下来发生的事情。显然，罗马人拼命想阻止哈斯德鲁巴。阻止哈斯德鲁巴与汉尼拔会合的最好方法就是阻止他离开伊比利亚。所以那年夏天初，西庇阿深入伊比利亚腹地。他袭击了哈斯德鲁巴的基地，并成功造成了严重伤亡。
casualties. But he can't prevent Hasdribal from doing a withdrawal from his base and nor over the next few months, can he prevent Hasdrabel from rebuilding his army? And by the winter of 208, Hasdrable has advanced through Spain over the Pyrenees and has arrived in Southern Gaul where he is wintering. And wintering in Southern Gaul gives him the opportunity to recruit lots of warriors from Gaul. The Gauls hate the Romans. This is what Hannibal had done when he'd gone. So his army is now really substantial. And come. spring the next year, so the campaigning season, he leads his army complete with 10 elephants over the Alps. And people may be wondering, well, we hear all about Hannibal crossing the Alps.
但他无法阻止哈斯德鲁巴从基地撤离，在接下来的几个月里，他也无法阻止哈斯德鲁巴重建军队。到了公元前208年冬天，哈斯德鲁巴已经穿过西班牙，越过比利牛斯山脉，抵达了高卢南部，并在那里过冬。在高卢南部过冬让他有机会招募大量高卢战士。高卢人痛恨罗马人。这就是汉尼拔当初所做的。所以他的军队现在非常庞大。第二年春天，也就是作战季节，他率领军队，带着10头大象越过了阿尔卑斯山。人们可能想知道，我们听说过汉尼拔翻越阿尔卑斯山。
We never hear about Hasrable crossing the Alps. What's going on? I mean, the reason is that he, you know, he does it expertly. He does it with incredible competence. And I think essentially the reason that we remember Hannibal's crossing is that he doesn't do it nearly as competently as Hasrable did. Anyway, so Hasdrable descends from the Alps. He arrives in northern Italy. And the Roman's worst nightmare has happened. There are now two huge armies, each one led by a Barker brother in their backyard. There are two consuls in Rome who have the job of stopping these two brothers. And one is in the north. He has six legions and he's got to stop. Hasdrable. And then there's one in the south with seven legions who's meant to be bottling up Hannibal. So the guy in
我们从没听说过哈斯德鲁巴翻越阿尔卑斯山。这是怎么回事？我的意思是，原因是他做得非常专业。他做得非常有能力。我认为本质上我们记得汉尼拔的翻越是因为他做得远不如哈斯德鲁巴那么出色。总之，哈斯德鲁巴从阿尔卑斯山下来。他抵达了意大利北部。罗马人最可怕的噩梦发生了。现在有两个庞大的军队，每一个都由巴卡家族的兄弟率领，就在他们的后院。罗马有两位执政官，他们的任务是阻止这两兄弟。一个在北方。他有六个军团，他必须阻止哈斯德鲁巴。另一个在南方，有七个军团，旨在困住汉尼拔。所以那个负责北方军团的人，我在你的笔记里读到，汤姆，他叫马库斯·利维乌斯·萨利纳托尔。
charge of the northern legions, I read in your notes, Tom, he is called Marcus Livius Salonitor. and he is, and I quote from your notes, a gloomy eccentric with terrible personal hygiene. I assume that all eccentrics have bad personal hygiene. How does his poor personal hygiene manifest itself, would you say? He's feeling very hard done by, and so as a protest, he has refused to wash or cut his hair, and so he's notorious for his body odour.
而且，引用你的笔记，他是一个“阴郁的怪人，个人卫生极差”。我假设所有的怪人都有糟糕的个人卫生。你会说他糟糕的个人卫生是如何表现出来的？他觉得自己受到了极大的不公，所以作为抗议，他拒绝洗澡或剪头发，因此他以体味浓重而闻名。
That's no way to inspire your men. And what about the guy in the South? The guy in the South is a member of the Claudian dynasty, one of the oldest and most prestigious dynasties. So he's called Gaius Claudius Nero and he's beautifully groomed, is he? Yeah, not a hint of body odour. These two folks, perhaps because of their dispute about grooming, despise each other. They absolutely loathe each other.
这可不是激励部下的好方法。那南方的那个人呢？南方的那个人是克劳狄王朝的成员，这是最古老、最显赫的王朝之一。所以他叫盖乌斯·克劳狄·尼禄，他打扮得很漂亮，是吗？是的，一点体味都没有。这两个人，也许是因为他们在仪容上的分歧，互相鄙视。他们绝对厌恶对方。
And so this is obviously a potential worry. I mean, will they be able to team up? But in the event, the contacts that exist between these two consuls turn out to be much more secure than the communication links between Hasdribal and Hannibal. So Hasdrable obviously is desperate to rendezvous with his elder brother and find a point where they can kind of meet up and combine their forces. And so he inevitably, you know, who are you going to turn to you when you want to deliver a message? Obviously in Numidians. So he gets a bunch of Numidians, supplements them with a few Gauls, writes out a message. And this message is meet in Umbria and he sends the Nehidians and Gauls off. And why Umbria? Well, this was the region where Hannibal had. one at Lake Trasamine, it's in northern Italy, it's on the way from the foothills of the Alps towards Rome. And this suggests that the Carthaginian plan was for the two brothers, once they had met up, to march directly on the capital and force the Romans to face them in battle.
所以这显然是一个潜在的担忧。我的意思是，他们能够合作吗？但事实上，这两位执政官之间存在的联系比哈斯德鲁巴和汉尼拔之间的通讯联系要安全得多。所以哈斯德鲁巴显然急于与他的哥哥会合，找到一个他们可以见面并合并兵力的地方。所以他不可避免地，当你想要传递信息时，你会求助于谁？显然是努米底亚人。所以他找了一群努米底亚人，补充了一些高卢人，写下了一条信息。这条信息是“在翁布里亚会合”，然后他把努米底亚人和高卢人派走了。为什么是翁布里亚？好吧，这是汉尼拔在特拉西梅诺湖获胜的地区，它在意大利北部，是从阿尔卑斯山山麓前往罗马的路上。这表明迦太基的计划是让两兄弟在会合后直接向首都进军，迫使罗马人与他们决战。
Because up to this point, the Romans, of course, had been avoiding meeting Hannibal in battle. And I think that, you know, their aim is we will stake everything on a single throw. see, for this to happen, Hasdrubal's message has to reach Hannibal. And the problem is that it doesn't, because it falls into the hands of Nero, the beautifully groomed Claudian consul, whose job it is to bottle up Hannibal in the South. And when he gets this message and reads it, he reacts, as Hannibal would have done in his sandals, with boldness and with an incredible display of initiative. So what Nero does is to trick Hannibal into thinking that he is still with his legions. He does this while he is simultaneously siphoning off a very substantial body of infantry.
因为到目前为止，罗马人当然一直在避免与汉尼拔正面交锋。我认为他们的目标是孤注一掷。看，要实现这一点，哈斯德鲁巴的信息必须传达给汉尼拔。问题是它没有，因为它落入了尼禄手中，那位打扮得漂漂亮亮的克劳狄执政官，他的任务是在南方困住汉尼拔。当他收到这条信息并阅读它时，他的反应就像汉尼拔会做的那样，大胆且展现了令人难以置信的主动性。所以尼禄所做的是欺骗汉尼拔，让他以为自己还带着军团。他在同时抽调出一支相当庞大的步兵部队时做到了这一点。
And he then marches with this body of infantry at incredible speed northwards towards where Salinator is refusing to have a wash. And as he marches, he is joined along the way by enthusiastic volunteers. so that by the time he reaches Salinators camp on the 22nd of June, he is bringing a very, very large body of men to join the Six Legions under Salinators camp. And Hasdrable has no idea at all that Nero has arrived until he hears in the morning not the one blast of the trumpet that signals the presence of a consul,
然后他带着这支步兵部队以惊人的速度向北进军，前往萨利纳托尔拒绝洗澡的地方。在他行进的过程中，他沿途得到了热情的志愿者加入。所以当他在6月22日到达萨利纳托尔的营地时，他带来了一支非常非常庞大的部队加入萨利纳托尔麾下的六个军团。哈斯德鲁巴根本不知道尼禄已经到达，直到他在早晨听到的不是那声标志着执政官存在的号角声，
but two. And this indicates to him that there are two consuls with their armies facing him. And you can imagine, I mean, his heart must have turned to ice. And so he thinks, oh God, this is terrible. I can't, you know, I'm going to be annihilated if I meet them. And so he tries to withdraw. But he has a problem because his line of retreat is blocked by a river called the Mataurus.
而是两声。这向他表明，有两位执政官带着他们的军队面对着他。你可以想象，他的心一定凉了半截。所以他想，天哪，这太可怕了。我不能，如果我面对他们，我会被歼灭的。所以他试图撤退。但他有一个问题，因为他的撤退路线被一条叫马陶鲁斯的河流挡住了。
And so he leads his men, they're kind of stumbling through the marshy banks of the Mataras trying to find a fording place. And as they're doing this, they're set upon by the Romans. And the battle is lost almost before it had begun. Now, it's true that the defeat was actually, I mean, it wasn't total. Had Hasdrubel survived, had he been able to lead his men and cross the Mataros and withdraw to the foothills of the Alps? I mean, he would entirely have been able to carry on the fight. But Hasrable dies in the thick of the fighting. I mean, he's very brave, but I think he's a bit stupid to have done that. Polybius says that he displayed in his death a fortitude and an ability of spirit worthy of his family name. But I don't think he displayed the shrewdness that Hannibal would have done in his situation, because his plunging into the thick of the melee essentially dooms his army and therefore, in the long run as we will see, dooms Hannibal. Now, when Hannibal had defeated the Romans at Can I, they had killed one of the commanders, a guy called Imelius Paulus. and Hannibal had shown the corpse of Paulus great respect.
于是他率领他的部下，在马陶鲁斯河沼泽般的河岸上跌跌撞撞地寻找渡口。就在他们这样做的时候，他们遭到了罗马人的袭击。战斗几乎在开始之前就已经输了。现在，确实，这次失败实际上并不是彻底的。如果哈斯德鲁巴幸存下来，如果他能率领他的部下渡过马陶鲁斯河并撤退到阿尔卑斯山山麓，他完全有能力继续战斗。但哈斯德鲁巴死在了激战中。我的意思是，他非常勇敢，但我认为他这样做有点愚蠢。波利比乌斯说，他在死时表现出的坚毅和精神能力配得上他的家族名声。但我认为他没有表现出汉尼拔在这种情况下会有的精明，因为他冲进混战中心基本上注定了他的军队的命运，因此，正如我们将看到的，从长远来看，注定了汉尼拔的命运。现在，当汉尼拔在坎尼击败罗马人时，他们杀死了其中一位统帅，一个叫埃米利乌斯·保卢斯的人。汉尼拔对保卢斯的尸体表现出了极大的尊重。
You know, he had not desecrated it. Nero and Salinator, when they find the body of Hasdrable, do not show it a matching respect. They cut off its head and they put Hasdribal's head into a sack and then they give it to a horseman. And this horseman gallops southwards, reaches the outposts that surround Hannibal's camp, gallops up to one of these outposts, hurls the sack at the feet of Hannibal's guards in this outpost, turns, wheels and gallops away. And the sack is brought to Hannibal, and Hannibal opens it, and he pulls out the severed head of his brother. And we are told that he mourns his brother, but that staring into his dead brother's features, he also mourns his city. and he cries out we are told
他没有亵渎它。尼禄和萨利纳托尔在发现哈斯德鲁巴的尸体时，并没有表现出同样的尊重。他们砍下了他的头，把哈斯德鲁巴的头放进一个袋子里，然后交给了一个骑兵。这个骑兵向南疾驰，到达了包围汉尼拔营地的哨所，冲向其中一个哨所，把袋子扔在汉尼拔哨兵的脚下，转身调转马头疾驰而去。袋子被带到汉尼拔面前，汉尼拔打开它，拿出了他哥哥被砍下的头颅。我们被告知他哀悼他的哥哥，但盯着他死去的哥哥的面容，他也哀悼他的城市。他大喊道，我们被告知
now at last I see the doom of Carthage Plain this is the moment I think when Hannibal knows that probably the game is up but not quite up because okay
“现在我终于看到了迦太基的末日”。这我认为是汉尼拔知道大势已去的时候，但还没有完全结束，因为好吧，
he's not going to be getting reinforcements to Liberia but the Romans are still they're so wary of his enormous military reputation they don't confront him in open battle so he actually now heads even further south doesn't he
他不会得到伊比利亚的增援，但罗马人仍然对他的巨大军事声誉非常警惕，他们没有在公开战斗中与他对抗。所以他实际上现在向更南边进发了，不是吗？
away from Rome into the heel of Italy, into what's called Brutium, and that's the area that he can hold most easily if the Romans are coming after him. He also, of course, does have a brother left. He has Mago back in Spain. And if you're Hannibal, you are probably thinking, well, if Mago can defeat Scipio in Spain, if he can win back the loyalty of the Iberians who've gone over to the Romans, who knows, maybe Mago can recapture New York. Carthage. Maybe he can raise a new army. Maybe he can send reinforcements to Italy. So, quite a lot of ifs. Yeah, there's a lot of ifs in any war. Unfortunately, not all of these ifs work out to Hannibal's advantage, do they? I mean, we said, Mago is a very good general. He's very, very dashing and very
远离罗马，进入意大利的脚后跟，进入所谓的布鲁提乌姆，如果罗马人追击他，那是他最容易守住的地区。当然，他还有一个兄弟。他在西班牙还有马戈。如果你是汉尼拔，你可能会想，如果马戈能在西班牙击败西庇阿，如果他能赢回那些倒向罗马人的伊比利亚人的忠诚，谁知道呢，也许马戈能夺回新迦太基。也许他能组建一支新军队。也许他能向意大利派遣增援。所以，有很多“如果”。是的，任何战争中都有很多“如果”。不幸的是，并非所有这些“如果”都对汉尼拔有利，不是吗？我的意思是，我们说过，马戈是一位非常优秀的将军。他非常非常意气风发，非常
competent. I mean, his problem is, for the first time, he is facing a Roman general who, you know, essentially is as able and inventive as Hannibal himself. And Skipio essentially, essentially, is going to crush all Hannibal's hopes because he is going to demolish the Carthaginian Empire in Spain. So in the spring of 206, he has cornered Mago at a place called Ilypho, which is north of what's now Seville, and they meet in battle. And alongside Mago is Masonissa, who's no longer a prince by this point, but a king, because his father died a few months before. And so he is now the leader of this kind of federation of Numidian tribes called the Mysulians. So he is, you know, I mean, he's now a very, very big player for the Carthaginians,
有能力。我的意思是，他的问题是，他第一次面对一位罗马将军，本质上和汉尼拔本人一样有能力和创造力。西庇阿本质上将粉碎汉尼拔所有的希望，因为他将摧毁迦太基在西班牙的帝国。所以公元前206年春天，他在一个叫伊利帕的地方把马戈逼到了绝境，那里在现在塞维利亚的北面，他们进行了交战。和马戈在一起的是马西尼萨，他此时已经不再是王子，而是一位国王，因为他的父亲在几个月前去世了。所以他现在是这个被称为马苏里安的努米底亚部落联盟的领袖。所以他现在对迦太基人来说是一个非常非常重要的角色，
not just a great commander, but an allied king. And so Mago and Massinissa, I mean, they must have been hopeful that they would be able to defeat Scipio. Mago would back himself. He knows that the Romans have always been kind of powerless against the Numidians. But no, it doesn't turn out at all. actually they find the battle that Scipio now forces on them. I mean, to put it mildly, a very, very bruising experience. So first, Massenissa's Numidian horsemen, you know, these great, great cavalrymen, they're swatted aside by Scipio's cavalry. So people will remember that when Scipio captured New Carthage, he'd insisted on lots of drill,
不仅是一位伟大的统帅，还是一位盟友国王。所以马戈和马西尼萨一定曾希望他们能够击败西庇阿。马戈会支持自己。他知道罗马人一直对努米底亚人束手无策。但没有，结果完全不是这样。实际上，他们发现西庇阿现在强加给他们的战斗，委婉地说，是一次非常非常痛苦的经历。首先，马西尼萨的努米底亚骑兵，这些伟大的骑兵，被西庇阿的骑兵击溃了。人们会记得，当西庇阿占领新迦太基时，他坚持进行了大量的操练，
lots of practice. Yes. And this is now paying off. because essentially he has transformed his cavalry into the best horsemen that Rome has ever had. And they just, you know, they, they swat massanista and his horsemen aside. There's then a stalemate, but one day passes, another day passes, another day passes, Mago's concentration drops, and this is the moment when Scipio attacks. And Mago, who we said had been, you know, he's a veteran of Can I, he'd stood in the lines alongside Hannibal.
大量的练习。是的，这现在得到了回报。因为本质上他已经把他的骑兵变成了罗马有史以来最好的骑兵。他们只是击溃了马西尼萨和他的骑兵。随后陷入了僵局，但一天过去了，又一天过去了，再一天过去了，马戈的注意力下降了，这就是西庇阿发动进攻的时刻。而马戈，我们说过他是坎尼的退伍军人，他曾与汉尼拔并肩作战。
He now finds that he is the one who is being. outflanked and enveloped by a smaller army. And Skipio has the winning of the battle. And although both Mago and Massinissa are able to escape the slaughter, Mago's army, which was the last effective force, left him in Iberia, is wiped out. I mean, to give mego credit, he still doesn't give up. So first of all, he tries to do a Scipio and launch an attack on New Carthage. In his case, it doesn't work. He gets beaten off. He then sails away. He found a new, naval base on the island of Mioka in the Balearics, which to this day bears his name, Mahon. And this apparently is where mayonnaise was invented. So in a way, mayonnaise is named after
他现在发现自己是被一支规模较小的军队侧翼包围的人。西庇阿赢得了这场战斗。虽然马戈和马西尼萨都成功逃脱了屠杀，但马戈的军队，那是他在伊比利亚留下的最后一支有效力量，被消灭了。我的意思是，给马戈一点赞誉，他仍然没有放弃。首先，他试图效仿西庇阿，对新迦太基发动进攻。对他来说，这没用。他被击退了。然后他乘船离开。他在巴利阿里群岛的米诺卡岛建立了一个新的海军基地，至今仍以他的名字命名，马翁（Mahon）。这显然就是蛋黄酱的发明地。所以从某种意义上说，蛋黄酱是以
Mago. I think it's the only popular condiment. It's a condiment, really? I was just thinking, is it a condiment? Well, if it's not a condiment, I don't know what it is. It's not a source, is it. It can be used as both, but it's, I think mayonnaise is more than, it contains multitudes. It's something you'd have in your fridge. And it's probably the only thing you'd have in a fridge that's named after a Carthaginian general. So it's kind of interesting detail. Anyway, so he's still on the scene. And then in 205, he launches a very ambitious invasion of northern Italy. You know, he takes ships, he takes men. He captures Genoa. So that's quite a feat. And he manages to hold out there against the Romans for three years. There's an indecisive battle. He gets wounded. The Carthaginians summon him
马戈命名的。我想这是唯一的流行调味品。它是调味品吗？我刚才在想，它是调味品吗？好吧，如果它不是调味品，我不知道它是什么。它不是酱汁，是吗？它既可以用作酱汁，也可以用作调味品，但我认为蛋黄酱不仅仅是……它包含万物。它是你会放在冰箱里的东西。而且它可能是你冰箱里唯一以迦太基将军命名的东西。所以这是一个有趣的细节。总之，他仍然在现场。然后在公元前205年，他发动了一次雄心勃勃的意大利北部入侵。他带了船，带了人。他占领了热那亚。所以那是一个相当了不起的壮举。他成功在那里抵御了罗马人三年。发生了一场不分胜负的战斗。他受了伤。迦太基人召回他
back to his home city and on the trip. He dies. So an energetic end. But that's the end of Mago. What about Massinissa? Well, for him, the days of fighting the Romans are now over, because this is the moment in the wake of Scipio's great victory at Ilippa, that he makes contact with the Roman victor. And the result is the meeting described by Livy, the homo erotic summit with which we began this episode. Because Massinissa is basically like the Iberians. I mean, he has no interest in fighting for a losing side. And it's very clear. to him by this point that the Carthaginians have no future whatsoever in Iberia. And so he, you know, he contacts Skippio. They get on tremendously well. And with Skipio's blessing, he returns to Africa there to secure his rule as king, because this other rival king, Sifax, is still on the scene. So he needs to sort that out. And Scipio, by sending Massinissa, now a Roman ally, to Africa, is obviously looking ahead. Because the only way that the one, war ultimately can be ended is if the Romans can take the war to Carthage itself.
回到他的家乡城市，在旅途中，他去世了。所以是一个充满活力的结局。但这就是马戈的终点。那马西尼萨呢？好吧，对他来说，与罗马人作战的日子现在结束了，因为这是在西庇阿在伊利帕取得伟大胜利之后，他与罗马胜利者取得联系的时刻。结果就是李维所描述的那次会面，也就是我们这集开头提到的那种“同性恋峰会”。因为马西尼萨基本上就像伊比利亚人一样。他对为失败的一方而战毫无兴趣。到此时他非常清楚，迦太基人在伊比利亚没有任何未来。所以他联系了西庇阿。他们相处得非常好。在西庇阿的祝福下，他回到了非洲，在那里巩固他作为国王的统治，因为另一个竞争对手国王西法克斯仍然在现场。所以他需要解决这个问题。而西庇阿通过派遣现在作为罗马盟友的马西尼萨前往非洲，显然是在未雨绸缪。因为最终结束战争的唯一方法是罗马人能够将战争带到迦太基本身。
And in late 206, Skippeer returns to Rome, doesn't he? And he is now a real star. He's had tremendous achievements in the battlefield. He's glamorous. He's charismatic. He's got his exciting long hair. And he is determined to win the prize that will confirm all this, which is the consulship. Yeah.
公元前206年末，西庇阿回到了罗马，不是吗？他现在是一位真正的明星。他在战场上取得了巨大的成就。他魅力四射，富有个人魅力。他留着令人兴奋的长发。他决心赢得能证实这一切的奖项，那就是执政官职位。是的。
Even though he's only 30 and legally you have to be 40 to become a consul. So he gets the consulship and he is allocated province, a very rich strategically important province that will be his once he has finished his consulship and that is Sicily. And the command in Sicily comes not just with boots on the ground, i.e. the legions, but it comes with a fleet of 30 warships. So this is what he needs. And on top of that, Dominic, crucially, he is given permission by the Senate, and I quote, to cross to Africa if he judged it to be in the interests of the Republic.
尽管他只有30岁，而法律规定你必须年满40岁才能成为执政官。所以他获得了执政官职位，并被分配了一个省份，一个非常富有且具有战略重要性的省份，一旦他完成执政官任期，那将是他的，那就是西西里岛。西西里岛的指挥权不仅带来了地面部队，即军团，还带来了一支由30艘战舰组成的舰队。所以这就是他所需要的。而且最重要的是，多米尼克，他得到了元老院的许可，引用原文，“如果他认为符合共和国的利益，可以跨海前往非洲”。
But the big question, will Scipio judge it to be in the interests of the Republic, to cross the sea, to invade Africa, and to attack the Carthaginians in their very backyard? There is only one way to find out. So if you're a member of the rest is History Club, and you want to find out whether the Scipio will indeed cross to Africa and launch the final assault on the Carthaginians. You can find out right now, because if you're a member of that club, you can hear episode three and indeed episode four of this series instantaneously. If you're not a member of the club, you'll have to wait gnawing at your nails like Gordon Brown in the aftermath of the financial crisis.
但最大的问题是，西庇阿会认为跨海前往非洲、入侵非洲并在迦太基人的后院攻击他们符合共和国的利益吗？只有一个办法可以找到答案。所以，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，并且你想知道西庇阿是否真的会跨海前往非洲并对迦太基人发动最后攻击。你现在就可以知道，因为如果你是该俱乐部的成员，你可以立即收听本系列的第三集甚至第四集。如果你不是俱乐部的成员，你将不得不等待，像戈登·布朗在金融危机后那样咬指甲。
But either way, the Punic Wars will continue and they will reach a devastating heart-stopping climax. Tom, thank you very much. Goodbye, everybody. Okay, so here's a glimpse of what's to come. If it sparked something unexplainable, then you can join us every Tuesday and Thursday for new episodes of The Rest of Science. I will figure it out together.
但无论如何，布匿战争将继续，并将达到一个毁灭性的、令人心跳停止的高潮。汤姆，非常感谢。再见，大家。好的，这就是即将发生的事情的预告。如果它激发了某种无法解释的东西，那么你可以每周二和周四加入我们，收听《科学的其余部分》的新剧集。我会一起弄清楚。
You mentioned earlier that a cup of water is like a rock smoothie, right? Because you've got rocks dissolved in it, magnesium and calcium. I would go a step further, though, and say that a glass of water is actually just a glass of lava. Right, right. Because I've talked about this before,
你之前提到一杯水就像岩石冰沙，对吧？因为里面溶解了岩石，镁和钙。不过，我会更进一步，说一杯水实际上只是一杯熔岩。对，对。因为我之前谈过这个，
and I bring it up whenever I can. Ice is a rock. Sure. Because, well, hold on, ice is a mineral. Because a mineral is just an inorganic material that is solid and has a definite crystal structure, which ice does. Water is important for life, but it's inorganic, actually.
而且我只要有机会就会提出来。冰是一种岩石。当然。因为，等等，冰是一种矿物。因为矿物只是无机材料，它是固体的，并且具有确定的晶体结构，冰确实有。水对生命很重要，但实际上它是无机的。
It would exist here, or whether there was life or not. And what that then means is that a cube of ice is made of a mineral. So it's a monomeralic rock. So melted ice is molten rock. Lava. So water is lava. I'm here
无论是否有生命，它都会存在于这里。这意味着一块冰是由一种矿物制成的。所以它是一种单矿物岩。所以融化的冰是熔融的岩石。熔岩。所以水就是熔岩。我在这里
for this. And this is not a joke. Ice won the mineral cup back in 2015, I believe. Some geologists all voted on their favorite mineral and ice finally got the recognition it deserves. Got the prize. Yeah. I mean, sure. I'm happy with that classification. If the rock people say it so,
支持这个观点。这不是开玩笑。我相信冰在2015年赢得了矿物杯。一些地质学家投票选出了他们最喜欢的矿物，冰终于得到了它应得的认可。获得了奖项。是的。我的意思是，当然。我对这种分类很满意。如果岩石专家这么说，
then I'm happy with it. They also move the same way. I mean, when lava gets spurted out of volcano, it uses the way that it moves and behaves is exactly the same. The fluid dynamics of lava. The fluid dynamics of lava is the same as water at that stage. Yeah. A bit later on when it cools down, then it's then it changes like ice. More like ice. There's a transition phase where it's more like toothpaste, where it needs a certain amount of sheer forces in order for it to flow. But that would be analogous to like slush maybe? Maybe. Yeah. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么我就很满意了。它们的移动方式也一样。我的意思是，当熔岩从火山喷发出来时，它移动和表现的方式完全一样。熔岩的流体动力学。熔岩的流体动力学在那个阶段和水是一样的。是的。稍后当它冷却下来时，它就会改变，就像冰一样。更像冰。有一个过渡阶段，它更像牙膏，需要一定量的剪切力才能流动。但这可能类似于雪泥？也许。是的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。